foreign  um  i was trying to get out of kiev  two days  and  luckily yesterday i got the free train  to live  and  and then we took  the taxi  and the taxi driver on the road he was  sneaking on the road and the police  stopped him and sent him back to libya  and we walked off  about 20 kilometer  and we are exhausted  i want to survive because i have a  family in europe  so right now in ukraine this dangerous  place because russian forces incoming  come from one more and every day is  strange time  you're saying nothing don't help us so  we don't have any chosen  we must do this something for survival  i have a problem with my  health and i have a  business and a ability in europe so it  can be and it can be possible but i  don't know right now it's i just want to  try  [Music]  you